Oh
so I recently watched a TED talk by
Jamie wheel of the flow Genome Project
the TED talk was called from altered
states to alter traits hacking the flow
state now you guys watch shots of awe
you know that I'm very passionate about
this idea of the flow state this state
of virtuosity and enhanced performance
among artists and musicians and writers
and elite athletes they go into this
zone where they experience this
transient hypofrontality this temporary
moment where the ego dissolves you get
sort of hyper focused in what you're
doing you drop into theta States like
meditating monks and you're able to
achieve excellence and virtuosity that
exceeds normal human levels and
thresholds for what's possible we
transcend ourselves in these moments of
the flow and Jamie Weil who co-founded
the flow Genome Project with Steven
Kotler
talks about it in his TED talk where he
says a lot of us know these flow States
but our self systems are like these
Hollanders we're like this colander full
of holes and no matter how much flow we
pour into it
we're always bleeding from this you know
this bucket full of holes and so we
achieve these temporary flow States but
then Monday we're back to where we were
as he says it's easier than ever to get
high it's as hard as it's always been to
stay that way but then the idea of
hacking flow means what if we could
transform this colander into a chalice
what if we could render ourselves whole
or as Jamie says render ourselves wholly
what becomes possible with just one drop
beyond that flow what becomes
possible with the rest I mean it's a
wonderful idea
most of us Jamie says you're still stuck
as like bliss junkies you know we get
stuck on the state without raising the
stage but now insights into the neural
physiology of the brain the neural
chemistry of the brain we can actually
have flow we can hack Nirvana we can
experience design and induce and design
our cities and our social systems with
positive self-reinforcing feedback loops
that teach flow to make flow an innate
natural emergence this is what becomes
possible and then who knows right as
Steven Kotler says in the book the rise
of Superman who knows what becomes
possible we become superhumans ah and
it's just uh it's an awesome idea and
it's up to us to make it happen
you